if you really did have knowledge of
history what would you do I think we're
gonna get like a nomad Steve Rogers
movie what he's just out just beatin on
people he's pounding asking them in the
closest retirement Tommy
great work yesterday all Christmas that
was our goal sending you into the
holiday was like we can't afford I
wasn't gonna surround myself with little
people and claim I was a Christmas God
this year I surrounded myself with tall
people and claimed that was a Christmas
goon season to talk about old man cap
for him well maybe actually you can
watch Eric answer that question very
clearly of how all of his old man cap
and is he going die soon yeah and we
went really into that he's gonna bury
all of us yeah but with me to answer
these questions of this episode a broke
theory is eric boss we're going to also
discuss the war between the streamers
streaming services but first we're still
thinking about okay a vendor sent game
how it both ended the stories of some of
our absolute favorite characters and it
potentially set the stage for the next
phase of the MCU and the next chapters
and there's a character that could or
could not maybe be involved in the
handoff here Steve Rogers end up in
America are you familiar yes
he ended as we saw as the old guy on the
bench you know slowly dying
we are also he's dying even slower than
we are as shows it is tight the
existence of the Black Widow movies show
the set even if a character dies it
doesn't necessarily mean that they don't
get their own movie story or if you they
don't get to be a guest on rogue theory
anymore right
so my question to you Tommy bet goes he
looks real tall yes spooky ghosts yeah
more of Medicine spook told his group
feels so real so my question to you is
assuming that we see more of Captain
America in the empty you how what's he
gonna be doing we're bringing back
everyone's favorite thing about Captain
America his beard because people mourned
the loss of that beer yeah listen I'm on
social media two hours a day legally
that's all I can all my devices has to
be shut off when Captain America shaved
his beard people were devastated it's
not yeah see see people were sad we like
the scruff we like the scruff but not
too much a taken it's an inside joke
between he and I and only us anyway I
feel like that's the only way you can
compel Chris evidence back into the role
is to be darker a little prettier we're
gonna take this timeline that is now
fresh to explore where you can do
anything and I think we're gonna see
ourselves in like 1985 a scruffy can
okay so not actually old old man no no
no go back to a period that we haven't
seen he said 1985 tommy 42 old yeah I
think well at that point if we look at
he would probably be like 60 55 yeah or
at least he'd have the the body of
someone that we did discuss that he ages
at a slower rate so he's actually in his
hundreds by the time we see him on the
bench but he has the body of a tight 80
year old right so I'm talking a ripped
six key
we're talking yeah you go to the beach
you look at your Uncle Phil and he has
not been skipping workouts he's a judge
in bel-air
trim and slim he's in heaven now with
Adam West he's still in how go back to
your month and a half ago yeah great
anyway so I think we're gonna get Rogers
character as Eric was right to help me
think it's not called The Drifter The
Drifter is just someone I dream about
the know and there's like right no man
no man no man Steve Rogers movie where
he's just out just beatin on people
what's that during the Cold War that
certainly could be maybe he's down maybe
he's down in South America when the
Russians were giving all the rat was it
the iran-contra affair well yeah the
well the spread of communism was the big
threat at the time it was going through
Central America and into South America
that's a new take on that too so that's
my pitch what was it a ram contra was
where Olly North was selling weapons to
rebels to do an anti-communist coup in
Guatemala oh you know more about that
than probably all of us at this table i
watch that episode of the Americans know
there you go yeah yeah I think that's
right that does sound right right cut
her hair and save the day yeah Wow
well these references are will be cut
Stockton New Kids on the Block has a new
album out yeah I love this idea Tommy uh
you got a rogue e because I really like
that that cap at that age I think that's
really interesting it also reminds me of
how red guardian looks like [ __ ]
Black Widow but this is kind of like
okay the actual Super Soldier Serum just
turns you into like well actually how
does Hugh Jackman right now in real life
yeah exactly so like even when he's like
60 or or Tom Cruise's so there these
people can still like kick ass yeah I
would love to see that movie and then I
of course maybe they're still younger
characters involved yeah he's got a hot
girlfriend he's got to have a hot
girlfriend it would be Sharon Carter
yeah yeah sure could be Sharon Carter
dating John Carter of Mars Jupiter of
Mars yeah yeah ghosts of Mars
Joe Carter Carter yeah great all right
well we answered it wrote there he's
done now guys what else could we see old
man kept it similar to to Tommy's theory
if we're assuming that cap is living in
an alternate history right an alternate
20th century history where he's Olivia
with Peggy I feel like there's like a
fascinating story there where imagine
your cat you're living in 1948 your
aging you're watching twentieth century
history play out and you already kind of
know what's gonna happen you know things
about the Cold War you know about
Kennedy's assassination is history as we
are then he knows nothing like that book
that he's like what is a Star War the
Almanac yes I mean he could be just bet
on famous remembers them I think he's
gonna face a lot of moral quandary zuv
which battles do I fight it's gonna be I
think we'll see cap in the 1950s like in
1960s maybe like facing some of these
major 20th century history historical
events like do I go into the jungles of
Vietnam and try to prevent like Vietcong
conflicts with the French Colonials do
in 1963 and try to stop Lee Harvey
Oswald it's gonna be like similar that's
Stephen King James Franco who Lou series
a 11/22/63 where it's like if you really
did have knowledge of history what would
you do you also just reminded me of two
things one is quantum leap right of
going bad more it's like I can help
certain things but if I help too much he
actually in the in quantum leap Scott
Bakula has the ability to prevent
Kennedy's assassination issue but then
also man in high school right where it's
like well what if he does adjust
something and then we get cat playing
out an alternate timeline yeah where you
know maybe the US isn't the dominant
power and he's still kept in America but
it's America is not a big deal anymore
yeah so you have this kind of like
interesting time travel story but the
traveling part is over it's just like
you're in a different time and like
having to face watch horrible things
happen but you're kind of powerless to
stop them and him dealing with that
battle oh and then he's caused like so
much more death and destruction somehow
and then when Sam's like so you want to
tell me about
I don't want to share what I've been
through you get a Rogi so both of these
ideas are our stud in the past and I
hadn't even been considering period
pieces for four Kappos imagining we have
said before but Batman Beyond basically
training new people or something Moreno
what's your angle your angles our ages
and my embraces the fact that cap is
mature we don't have to call them old
cap we can call him wise cap boomer cap
so boomer cap is gonna is gonna be the
mentor to Falcon and Winter Soldier but
he's not he's retired and on purpose
he's retired so he doesn't he although
he has a tight bod as you keep repeating
screaming the tightest
yeah press it against my forehead and
threaten me put your body that is a pile
of ropes and wrap it around me as tight
as you can even though he could do all
of those things and we want him to he's
not going to because he's retirement
purpose he's lived his life he's done
all these things and he's there to give
training and wisdom to the people that
he passed on his mantle to purposefully
because he wants him to learn he wants
him to grow and you can't grow if
someone's doing everything for you so
maybe he's in maybe he's like just I
don't want it well you know what he's
pounding ass in them in the closest
retirement just slamming puss right he's
gone living his cat as a mature man and
the only time he wants to be bothered is
when Falcon and Winter Soldier are in
like dire straits and they're like if we
need advice from mm-hmm and they pull
him out of heaven and they pull him out
of heaven but it's but at that beep he
has to be enjoying his laughs all about
something yeah heaven is the 74 year-old
Ripper in the 1930s he's retired he's
done his job marina already gets a
Wragge
mostly Borg always I always love to be
able to bring up that there is rampant
sex happening in these old-age homes and
[Laughter]
and that's what he said he was sharing
his quote wisdom he's living his full
best life he's there to help his friends
when they need him gotcha okay so he's
uh maybe curmudgeonly
I sure you might be curmudgeonly but he
shows up in the new series unguent e+
and he also he doesn't necessarily have
to be Chris Evans because he's old and
his makeup he could be what if he's just
an actual older actor let's give some
Jon Voight for everything political
opinions let's put them in casting let's
let's do it let's get Stuart yeah he
already is a cab yes give them back to
me in a tweet everybody we can start
with over there cap back in time
deciding which history to change in
which history to watch through tears
captain no no mad as a go in this
alternate tale of pals seeking trials to
find who is George trials but also the
previous round was pails for pals
pals Bale try out or try out
a great character from Legendary's no
more Alfred's great okay boomer cap
retires the shield but not that dick
whoa as he goes on to help Falcon and
Winter Soldier as their mentor hashtags
women pregnant back like Easter Bunny
he's putting them back into meta buddy
make women fertile again yes did I hear
an alternate Televi what else does he do
I was told he always just puts eggs back
inside of woman's wolf take this quarter
Rogge and solve Tommy's issues not too
bad the doctor even said 75% you're okay
[Laughter]
in the comments let us know did any of
this make sense but what do you think is
actually gonna happen with old man can't
we have a little while until we find out
but we will hold you accountable yeah
to what you've said and what you did
over the break guys let's take a quick
break okay hey guys I'm back in the blue
dungeon to thank the sponsor this video
bang energy every can of bang is 16
ounces that's right there no wimpy 12
ounce cancers anywhere in sight it
contains at 300 milligrams of caffeine
it is sugar-free and as zero calories
and it tastes great with 20 different
flavors to choose from one of these
grape flavors is cherry blade lemonade
and let's crack open this baby see what
work
you got the cherry you got your lemonade
and you got the blade that cuts back and
forth between them lately
look they're just some mornings where I
wake up after ray Jenn just kidding like
rewatching Attack of the Clones and when
my veins are feeling like they're full
of sludge I can a bang energy just helps
pick me up so that I can cherry blade
lemonade through any work I got to do
check out bang on Instagram you can get
25% off your order at bang - energy calm
when you use the code new rock stars 25
that's a discount worth of toes there
you can get a variety 12 back with a
dozen of their flavors flavors like pina
colada cotton candy and rainbow unicorn
have you ever tasted a rainbow unicorn
unicorn well thank you and so will your
taste buds thanks again to bang energy
for sponsoring this video get 25% off at
bang energy com using code new rock
stars 25 and follow the inventor of bang
on instagram at bang energy that's CEO
alright welcome back guys so it is
insane how well the streaming services
are actually doing right now I know all
of you bet against them and you all were
wrong every single one of you but we
don't know who's gonna be the champion
of this thing and we decided what the
hell we're gonna decide who is the
utmost winner of the streaming wars this
is huge Royal Rumble style whoo you can
throw them out of the ring and it's
scripted this whole let's fight is
scripted but no actually I want you guys
to pick between you ready yeah Apple TV
plus or a plus River Disney Plus Amazon
Prime
Hulu and then the old-school daddy
Netflix and then we'll say if you want
to go after HBO Max and peacock yeah
you're free but you're digging your own
grave alright this is serious your till
death Erik get us started
okay I'm gonna jump on the obvious one
Disney Plus but I think it's gonna be
the champion for reasons that are not so
obvious okay so first off Disney Plus
had a pretty solid rollout with shows
like the mandalorian they're gonna
continue having streaming series
throughout 2020 and 2021 they're gonna
ramp up they're gonna have four
different Marvel streaming series and
that add that on top of their expanding
catalog but what's crazy about what
they're gonna be able to do I believe
one thing we learned from this past year
in in 2019 what through this whole
spider-man deal with Sony I think we are
setting up
or Disney set themselves up to profit
even more from the spider-man character
which is Sony's real cash cow I think it
a couple years they're gonna buy out
Sony so within a couple years they're
gonna get all of Sony's catalogue and
material so that adds Disney Pixar Star
Wars Marvel Plus all the stuff they got
from Fox that includes The Simpsons
which is already on Disney Plus and
they're gonna get all Sony's catalog to
back catalog of spider-man movies
they're Jumanji films the Bond films
it's all gonna be on one platform and
right now I think the big complaint
about Disney Plus is that it doesn't
have like an option for just like adults
who want to watch like an r-rated movie
that they liked like currently Disney
owns Deadpool and they don't have an M
additional plus so are they gonna
release it on Hulu no I think after year
one Disney's gonna they already have
this all mapped out dark Disney dark or
Disney plus plus X and we're gonna see
they're gonna have an additional tier
four for pg-13 and r-rated leaning
content one of the first time Peter
who's ever downloaded was Donald like
getting a [ __ ] Erik's theory is
basically Disney is the blob yeah and I
think they have this all planned out
that's gonna be like a duopoly between
Disney and all of its holdings and
whatever Warner can muster if it buys
out Netflix it's a pretty good argument
you're gonna get a Rogi but Disney just
will buy everything it seems exactly
yeah because they're they're already
playing it's so smart by integrating
everything with their theme parks which
makes more money than most of their film
and TV properties just those parks alone
in their merchandising opportunities so
right now they are ahead of every other
studio in terms of merchandising and
turning their experiences into places
you can visit pay a lot of money walk
into and explore on your own and and
that's the bottom line is what we call
you Erik bottom line bus you know who
they don't have more money than Amazon
that's why I am going to argue on behalf
of Amazon Prime which has all of the
things that Disney has - obviously
they're their direct contact but they
have original series they have movies
they've original movies
they have aggregated content from other
other production companies that they buy
and they license they also have the
rental option for everyone else's
property so you can stay within one
subscription to Amazon Prime and you can
still rent a Disney movie I could go
rent inside out yeah for $2.99
no granted if I obviously if I'm gonna
rep more than four disney movies a month
it's worth rent getting dizzy plus but
if not if you're just gonna get one or
two disney plus movies a month why not
just rent them and then have your amazon
prescription Prime subscription which
comes with Amazon Prime delivery also so
you're getting so much more than just
the streaming networks
that's actually why Amazon shows are
what they are is that the vast majority
of Amazon Prime viewers are actually
people just signed up yeah a service
yeah it means they're wealthy enough to
so all of their shows skew older for
that reason well in what do you think
Disney will continue to license all
their film properties to a competitor I
think so because you make a ton of money
that way sure that banks demand content
this is what I think now I don't know if
any of yous about to take Netflix from
there but things like oh really okay
well things like the office and Parks
work anything owned by NBC that's gonna
go to peacock I think peacock is not
really gonna do great but they're gonna
license it to everybody and then I don't
know what Netflix is going forward after
that but maybe well tell you real quick
just for going on the limp shout out to
Jeff Bezos we went to high school
together
no not together but he went to my high
school and so now he's like the second
most successful person I went to my high
school yeah I'm on the Netflix side for
a couple of the reasons that you touched
on which is that like Disney Plus
doesn't have anything for adults right
and the an Amazon Prime has stuff for
like older older adults like you know
like boomers wake up
yeah well man kept slamming Gatorades
and 4:00 p.m. go to bed but here's the
thing the Netflix does and it's
established itself as this and it
continues to provide this to people who
are in between those
ages and everybody in between like just
everybody who wants to sit down and go I
don't know what I want to watch I'm
going to discover it as I browse through
this thing it's the closest thing to TV
right like TV we used to sit down and go
like oh what's on TV and if you're not
like you only I only go on Disney plus
if I know what I want to watch and I
know like I want to watch lady in the
[ __ ] but I have never sat down which I
do guys I do want to watch that live
action I did watch both yeah mm-hmm it's
good it's cute but I have never not one
time sat down and been like I'm gonna
browse Disney Plus same thing with
Amazon I'm either there to rent
something specific but I sit like when I
don't know what I want what to watch I
sit down and I turn on Netflix and I
browse and I discover content cuz they
have so much content they also have
nostalgic stuff that Disney Plus has and
they were the first powerhouse that
started the reason that these platforms
even exist is because Netflix came out
with house of cards and won 13 Emmys or
whatever so and then all of the other
entertainment companies went like oh
[ __ ] we have to start competing and
they're the original ones and they have
I mean stranger things unbelievable is a
very good show house of cards like you
discover things on there and you go like
wow I just found out what this is and
it's amazin efflux is success is the
reason Fox sold to Disney why that huge
sale went through is because Fox looked
down the line in the future and realize
there's no way they could compete mm-hmm
yep you guys aren't holding back at all
you're this real cutthroat argument the
granddaddy Network with the mask catalog
versus the most money argument versus
the awesome ass catalog ban you guys
went real brutal with it and boy was
that section cut tightly do I get uh
well since you asked you get one oh wait
they already give you one for doing the
gesture
okay shortest rogen guys it's time for
real questions oh we haven't seen him I
haven't seen him and nobody seen him
nobody gonna stay home it's Christmas
time it was what gift would you get your
favorite MCU character
I'm suit character and what gift you
would get them oh I get everyone a baby
Yoda Wow everyone in the MCU everyone
gets a baby Yoda because you calm down
and everyone stops fighting and they all
just want to be a nurturer all right
every character even the villains in the
MTU every babysit delayed Tommy I would
get the Hulk make a Bruce Banner and his
permanent hulks and my hog stay home
cleaning for a year because I imagine he
knocks over a lot of stuff yeah cuz he's
not used to having a body like that so
you know I remember he gained a lot of
weight after college and I started
knocking things over more and someone
gave me full-time care it was actually
state mandated I had to have a nurse
with me at all times but it meant so
much that the state of New York gave me
that yeah and I'd like to pass that on
but that nurse made you really angry a
time soon so you would not step over
because yeah and she didn't like me when
I was angry or did he not like me when I
was angry the nurse was a man Philip
thank you getting what I'm gonna get cap
a lifetime supply of a lifetime supplies
from both these people you guys are
spending money so long Disney is
planning another Planet of the Apes
movie
what other Disney you guys are very
different on this what other Disney
property would make for a fun Planet of
the Apes crossover song of the south all
right guys Josh Brolin said on social
media a day he burned his butthole while
sunbathing his pucker hole all charred
up guys which infinity stone to be the
best for curing a burned butthole
I think the soul stone that's kind of
because you have to make a great
sacrifice to come back from burning your
be whole right like there's with that
only only death can replace death
butthole is burned you have to burn
something else to heal your tender hole
or what about the time stone we know the
time stone does have an influence over
digestion with dr. Strange's Apple so
like is it burnt because of what he
passed through it it's it he said while
son baby it was a sudden who's
sunbathing and ate some food that didn't
sit well with them boneless buffalo
wings whose my guess endless boneless
buffalo wings and just not think about
your burn hole force let's say who said
butthole the most times I said push
Brina this one you get a dirty Rogge
which is actually in the lead marinas
wish comes true sorry
alright Tommy and Eric have to trade
places doing impressions of each other
for the rest of the episode yeah so it's
chairs Oh
switch chairs why is there no cocaine on
this issue great great they it was state
mandated
I have to stay at home because I have to
be attended and chaperone at all times
my parents will talk to be no go Oh slow
you know we find you first of all thank
you guys so much for having me it's
always such an honor to be here
yesterday I was doing my Christian
ministry I was using on just how
wonderful life is and how much I love
people and it's just such a great
feeling to be here with you guys my wife
Sharon and I are expecting our third
child and and honestly God is so good to
us right now I don't even feel worth I
don't feel like I need to promote things
because everything about me is promoting
joy and godliness and good fulness and I
just I want to say
Tommy you don't owe me any money okay
buddy almost forgiven Tommy is that okay
with you yeah you got another one off
these notes look up big titties look up
even bigger titties I would never say
that
hugest titties Google has to offer
Tommy why are you so worried about
Eric's notes being revealed all holes
what is this Tommy don't eat that and
that is a very top impression
Brina math shows big money at Marina
masters and great all right guys that's
episode of rogue theory find me wherever
you want by me wherever I am bye
[Music]